E aí
meu nome é Carlos Henrique Nasser Veiga
meu nome artístico aí que Veiga nome do
meu palhaço ipsis litteris e como me
chamo meu apelido enfim desse sempre
Eric desde pequeno mas também desde
pequeno até agora de muitas coisas já me
chamaram Já me chamaram de quick de
Carlão de gordo de Zig aqui se quiser
era de amor filho molin rolé pai
Oi e eu trabalho também né desses papéis
cruzeiros isso é como advogado
criminalista ator palhaço diretor e
professor de teatro e coordeno um
artisticamente um projeto de palhaço que
visitam hospitais
e também atua como o pai filho espírito
santo e profano tu tá mesmo tempo
Oi e aí eu fico vendo assim parece que
são as relações as situações dos
contextos da nossa vida que nos dão a
nossa Persona ou nos convidam a uma
Persona inclusive e não nos damos nomes
muitas vezes
existe um cara da psicoterapia corporal
da Psicologia formativa O Stanley
keleman Ele disse que somos vários Rios
ou pelo menos somos uma possibilidade de
vários
a criança quando ela nasce é ela começa
a descobrir o mundo tem os seus órgãos e
expansão seus sentidos e começa a
descobrir o mundo através dos Sentidos
das Sensações do corpo ela põe mundo na
boca ela escuta ela cheira né E e aí ela
faz sons
sons orgânicos que saem de dentro dela
que tem a ver com que ela está sentindo
Oi e o corpo dela então é ele brinca a
criança ela brinca com esse mundo que se
torna um parque de diversões e ao mesmo
tempo pode ser extremamente assustador
todas essas novidades mas o fato aquela
ver tudo e sente tudo pela primeira vez
e pela primeira vez e pela primeira vez
e aí chegou um momento que a criança
começa a se separar um pouco desse
espelho que é o mundo
oi e ela começa a conhecer outros seres
e ela começa também a ser outros seres e
a brincar de outros seres Então ela
começa a ser pirata as e árvore a ser
cachorro gato ela começa a brincar
daquilo que ela ver o adulto fazendo ela
começa a lavar louça a brincar de
cozinhar de dar aula de ser médica e
tudo isso ela faz com muita seriedade
muito concentrada
se refere a brincadeira da criança
O que é muito sério isso né a criança se
a gente vê ela não tá fazendo piadinha
e ela tá vivendo aquilo de verdade
aí
nós adultos é que começamos a ver a
brincadeira como uma mentira
a brincadeira começa a ser sinônimo de
mentirinha a isso de mentira isso é
brincadeira
e aí essa criança que tem o corpo livre
que brinca que bota a camiseta na boca e
senta meio torta que anda de várias
maneiras ela começa ouvir Não grita não
rir não chora não corre não pula anda
direito Senta direito e aquele corpo
todo começa a 11
nós ficamos erectus Esse é o início
imitamos os nossos movimentos E também
limitamos o acesso Talvez as nossas
emoções e aos nossos sentimentos
Oi e a ser esses vários ela começa a
isso com Deus sentimentos que eu chamo
de sentimentos proibidos partir do
momento começam a ser proibidos o medo a
raiva a tristeza tudo isso a gente
aprende como feio e quando a gente sente
a gente segura a gente vai aguardando
vai guardando e não demonstro
Oh e vamos aprendendo a nos padronizar a
ter um comportamento uma postura
corporal padronizada e a reações e ações
padronizadas O que funciona não é ruim e
o que ele me disse que funciona preciso
termos esses padrões o problema é quando
a gente se identifica com esses padrões
e acredita que a gente é esse padrão e
passa a ser só ele sendo que a gente tem
uma possibilidade menção de ser quando a
gente não se conecta com que tá sentindo
porque antes é talvez fazia assim quando
estava apavorado ou fazer assim que eu
tava Alegre e daí daqui eu vim para cá é
mas tem uma coisa e ficou ou daqui eu
vim para cá uma coisinha ficou mas é
muito parecido isso isso aqui para ser
parecido com isso se confunde tudo a
gente já não sabe mais direito que a
gente tá sentindo
G1
E aí eu trabalhei com o advogado
criminalista ainda trabalho É mas
trabalha no escritório de advocacia e o
meu trabalho basicamente era tirar da
cadeia quem tá preso ou evitar que seja
preso aquele que está na iminência de
ser né e eu comecei então a trabalhar
com a liberdade das pessoas a lutar por
ela e a liberdade sempre para mim foi
uma questão muito forte sou Juliano e
assim eu tenho um problema eu não aceito
a prisão tem uma dificuldade de aceitar
a prisão então eu às vezes me misturava
naqueles casos eu ficava Muito
angustiado alguém tava preso não
aceitava aquilo aqui que soltar de
qualquer maneira E aí Aquilo me fazia
sofrer muito e eu comecei a perceber que
aquela pessoa aquela situação estava
servindo como um espelho
é de mim eu tava vendo as minhas prisões
mas é que eu estou preso em algumas
dores ainda estava estou né
então tive uma crise fui para o
psicólogo ou psiquiatra enfim um dia eu
fui assistir uma peça de teatro o texto
a queda do álbum de caminho ensinada
pelo Mauro Zanatta e assim que a ser
menor que a peça era uma peça que falava
sobre um advogado em crise de
consciência e assim que acabou a peça eu
falei é isso que eu quero fazer porque
eu vi um ator falando com verdade algo
que eu jamais tinha visto um advogado
falar sobre si mesmo
é mais verdade do que o próprio advogado
eu entrei lá dentro no camarim falei eu
queria fazer isso você me ensina aí ele
falou olha eu tenho mais cola de teatro
se você quiser você pode se matricular e
sim aí eu me matriculei aí comecei a
fazer teatro e nessa de fazer teatro eu
comecei a mexer meu corpo
e a linha de teatro que a gente estudava
era muito corporal gente trabalhava com
máscaras então era muito expressão
corporal como você mexer meu corpo a de
novo experimentar audição Tato né
Paladar pequeno teatro Nati tudo muito
bem vindo essas sensações né os sentidos
E aí isso nisso eu vi que eu tava
começando acessar que estes dois
pessoais emocionais minhas tava muita
coisa vindo à tona e eu falei Opá de
alguma coisa ligada aí né Aí fui fazer
uma formação em psicoterapia corporal
e lá eu vi tudo isso que a gente tá
voltando no corpo essas coisas que a
gente é Nossa história está toda
registrada no nosso corpo enfim né a
gente vai sublimando as coisas e tal e
aí eu conheci também o autor lá que é o
inicot buscar na lista que diz que é
pelo brincar que a pessoa seja ela
adulta ou criança acesso a sua liberdade
criativa e portanto o seu self
e o seu selfie talvez como um eu uma
essência né que ela pode vestir esses
vários
ela se descobre ela cria a todo tempo
assim como a criança na brincadeira está
criando como a gente quando está
presente numa relação a gente está
criando o tempo todo se a gente está
presente não só na nossa máscara social
e aí eu vi que então é por isso que tá
mexendo tanto e eu tô resolvendo algumas
questões emocionais eu tava podendo
brincar de ser vários erros de novo
e eu podia no teatro é isso para mim
fazer teatro é brincadeira alguma coisa
e mais eu tava podendo vivenciar os
sentimentos proibidos porque todo mundo
bem vindo a raiva o medo a tristeza no
teatro também nas artes são bem-vindas
né E aí vivendo tudo isso tá aí eu
conheci uma figura
que eu me apaixonei que é o palhaço
ou a palhaço né que eu falo uma figura
Porque para mim não é o personagem é um
estado o palhaço é um estado de ser
e esse ser brincante talvez tenha alguma
coisa a ver com selfie que pode se
transvestir brincar e essa figura tudo
aquilo que a gente vai escondendo vai
escondendo vai escondendo vai escondendo
desde pequeno essa figura vem e revela e
ela mostra e ela incorpora aquilo
evidencia aquilo os nossos fracassos os
nossos defeitos os tabus sociais e
pessoais por palhaços são grandes
material são as nossas sombras ele põe
luz através dessa lanterninha vermelha
na lâmpada vermelha que ilumina né então
a gente começa a enxergar essas sombras
de vivenciar poder se vestir delas então
palhaço aquele desajustado é o
inadequado da sociedade é um fracassado
é aquele que tem sapato maior que o pé e
vai botar um chapéu e não cabe na cabeça
que tem uma flor enorme porque sim
porque ele acha bonito Aquilo é alguém
que e quando sentimento treme né quando
quando tu dá risada rola no chão de
tanto rir é alguém que vai chorar e
espirra água na plateia veja depois de
muitos anos trabalhando como palhaça que
eu fui entender o que que esse choro que
espirra na plateia enquanto a gente era
criança eu via não chora o palhaço vem
depois de chora espirrando água para
fora
bom então essa figura que é o que a
gente é
mas que não pode parecer em sociedade é
o Coringa do baralho que pode ser
qualquer outra carta carta que for
necessário no momento né então ele pode
ser rei pode ser dama pode ser a isso
pode ser tudo isso só que ele também
suja Canastra o jogo porque ele é sujo
porque somos né então ele também tem
esse lado sombra que ele mostra então
ele é o rei que o rei É mas não pode
parecer
bom né então ele vai ser o rei que vai
sentar no trono e solta um pum e ao
mesmo tempo súdito palhaço que está ali
abanando é aquele que sente o cheiro
esse afeta e nem demonstro então e ele
vai ser a rainha dama que vai descer uma
escadaria que abre o salto Vai tomar um
chá esse queima de rama né vai ser o
soldado que na trincheira tem medo do
escuro que levou para guerra ursinho de
pelúcia para se sentir seguro Então são
essas humanidades e fazem do palhaço uma
figura muito poderosa a meu ver ele
precisa se conhecer e conhecer o que é
humano
e
o palhaço tem esse poder de erro bobo da
corte o único que pode dar um chute na
bunda do Reddit
Ah mas se ele fizer isso na hora errada
ele pede a cabeça na guilhotina
então ele vive nesse risco diante do
Abismo esse risco é o que que é o
presente que se não saber né é esse
risco que
esse tempo esse fazer correto é esse
tempo certo de agir de chutar a bunda do
Rei Não é racional ele é orgânico como é
quando a criança brinca ele tá ele diz
respeito ao presente a estar presente e
fluindo de uma maneira muito natural e
óbvia até né então ele está sempre
diante de si risco do abismo e aí eu
lembro dos desenhos animados né que tá
diante do Abismo daí dá um passo e um
sujo uma tábua aí eu te passo ou tratar
a outra tava quando vê atravessou o
abismo pouco não sai correndo um abismo
e aí tá correndo no aro né nos desenhos
animados aí você para que tá no ar um
esse repara Talvez o nosso fra a ação da
cabeça com que é orgânico Como que é o
corpo com as nossas emoções que na
verdade estão muito ligadas então é essa
figura me apaixonei muito por esse
motivo né é um espelho quando a gente
olha o palhaço caindo a gente rir e a
Gente Se alivia Ufa ele caiu
eu também galho ou melhor eu me seguro o
dia inteiro para não cair a vida inteira
me segurando para não quebrar o salto
Quando eu descer a escadaria né então e
o palhaço se permite é isso é uma
permissão Da gente ser falho é que a
gente é de ser ridículo ele se põe a
serviço para ser desprezível ah e também
é bem sucedido e habilidoso e é tudo
isso né Então essa figura Cada vez que a
gente olha a gente se identifica de
alguma forma com essa a gente vive numa
sala de espelhos Talvez o e o estado
presente quando eu digo de brincar eu
não tô falando que precisa ser ator ou
atriz ou palhaço palhaça para ter a
brincando com um adulto o brincar
duoplay né inglês são vários
significados é brincar e jogar é a
própria espetáculo de teatro é se
relacionar então é sobre isso não é um
jogo de ganhar e perder é estar jogando
estar presente ali né para quem não quer
novo vendo pela primeira vez a gente
compra pão assim quatro coisas por favor
obrigado deve tá E vai né
uma criança por exemplo quando ela tá
brincando ela faz um negocinho ela olha
e fez outra coisa olha ela olha ela
considera quem tá ali ela convida ela tá
incluindo
entende a gente que não faz assim a
gente exclui a Gente Tá negando a
existência
de quem tá ali na nossa frente da
existência inclusive daquele momento
e a gente tá ligando né Então essa essa
relação estar em relação pode ser um
espelho da gente agora Limpo um aquela
imagem de ficar infinito né eu gostava
de falar com a minha mãe no provador daí
tinha um espelho aqui outro espelho aqui
e o espelho de frente para o outro era o
infinito eu penso que se a gente se
colocar como um espelho diante de um
outro espelho Pode ser que nessa relação
haja possibilidade de vivenciar um
infinito ali algo extremamente novo né e
tal nessa esse jogo é mas enfim tudo
isso a gente foi calado ou coisas assim
o aprendeu a não viver dessa maneira tão
presente porque esse espelho também me
mostra minhas dores minhas angústias
elas que quando pequeno não subir lidar
eu aprendi a fugir a esconder elas e
quem me ensinou a fugir a esconder não
fez por mal porque também não soube
lidar porque também foi calado coisa
assim quando uma criança que esperneia e
grita na nossa frente aqui no gera uma
um grito não é um grito interno Ela
jogou uma coisa na parede e a minha
vontade de jogar na parede e aquilo eu
não sei lidar com aquilo então tem três
formas comum da gente fazer hoje de Cala
não é para com isso ou abandona deixa lá
que daqui a pouco passa ou a gente diz
traga o passarinho passarinho ó e aí
passou mas em todas essas possibilidades
a gente está negando a gente não tá
incluindo aquilo não tá ali tentando
atravessar é preciso aprender a supor e
a gente precisa suportar e permitir ou
não saber né
então se for para gente viver numa
sociedade assim hoje a gente precisa das
máscaras que a gente conheça as máscaras
mas possa se desindente ficar com elas
para poder ser se eu esse selfie e vai
vestir qualquer um esse ser brincante
que brinca série de verdade não é
gracinha hein [ __ ] e a gente tem então
uma arara guarda-roupa cheio de máscaras
né E para vestir eu vou escolher qual
que eu vou não não sou tomado por ela eu
escolho qual que eu visto e vou para
relação àquele contexto E se eu não
souber qual máscara usar eu uso a menor
do mundo
E aí
E olha que o circo chegou
o hino Teu Palhaço preferido aquele like
perdido e que parece amador trocando o
riso pelo choro para pedir teu consolo
procurando domador
anda Sai de cima do muro e traz para
esse [ __ ] dele escuro o teu sorriso
refletor hoje não é teu futuro Bem Viver
um personagem quem sabe até um grande
amor vem tirar a maquiagem desse palhaço
sonhador e verás em seus olhos
Espelho
Espelho Meu
e esse palhaço Amor
o soro
E aí